instead of just learning maths and
science these children are also being
taught how to identify mortars grenades
and signs of landmines
mistaking them for toys could cost them
their lives
the streams were dry so we were looking
for water then an old man shouted at us
that there's a big snake nearby and he
tried to cover it with grass it was
actually a rocket so we left the area
fearing there might be more bombs
non-profit groups like the halo trust
are working to prevent more casualties
one way is to paint rocks the white side
means the path has been cleared red
points to areas with potential mines
buried underneath
yes i'm afraid but i know that when i
see white stones we can play there and
when it's red we can't play there
since 1989 more than forty thousand
people in afghanistan have been killed
or injured by land mines and unexploded
ordinance according to the u.n
a few months ago bismillah's wife lost
both of her legs in an explosion just
outside their home
this incident was very painful i saw it
happen with my own eyes i saw my
children screaming and crying the scene
was very painful for me i feel alone and
the stress is too much too much
now others like him are employed by
groups to help locate mines before they
explode we also give jobs to people who
would otherwise be in the fight we give
jobs to young men who
are forced through desperation to join
the insurgency or
had joined the army and so we can give
peaceful work we take the rifle off them
and we give them a mind detector
over the past three months about a
hundred explosive devices have been
diffused in the region including 25 in
this village
we were there
with the russians we were there with the
civil war we were there with the first
taliban regime we were there with nato
and we will stay
thousands more landmines are believed to
lie undetected a legacy of war that
continues to maim and kill
leo harding al jazeera